それでははい なんかはい
ガーメーがですね 一つの村をずっと托鉢するという意味ですよね
でもいろんな村を回って
ややこしい ガーメーソと書いていいわけないでしょうに
村々にあることや 格好悪いんじゃないんですか？文法的にも
ツルーラが あのツッパンガですね
アジュタって意味でしてますよね
ん？ ツッパンガ アジュタって意味でしてますよね
だから花を  だからミツバチにしてもいっぺんに花つ止まりませんでしょ
ミツバチ 1匹は 1個のお花に止まるでしょうに
お坊さんもどうやって 2つの村同時に歩くんですかね
家一件一件歩くんだから
よくくだらんことを考える暇があるな
だからガーメーは複数にするとガーメーソになるでしょ
意味がないとにかく  そうじゃなくてですね
村を 村を なんていうんですかね
村を歩くっていうか という風にアジュタで取れないかなと思ったんですけど
あのミツバチは花を渡り歩くわけですよね
ですからアジュタで通ってますよね
まあなるほど ガーメーはロケティブじゃないでしょうね
一応 アクセプティブに出るんでしょうかね
もう一応これロケーションだからどうしてもロケティブになります
これはもう日本語ではアクセプティブになりますね
でもパーリ語ではやっぱりもうロケティブに場所だからね
アクセプティブにはどうしてもなりません
先生 お釈迦様は 3回ほとんど死にかけたと仰ったんですが
それはどのように復活されたんでしょう
まあ仮死状態だからね
やっぱりまたまあ復活しました
それだけ  あとよろしいですか？誰が
すいません  どうぞ  よろしいですか
4行目にムニという風にありますが
これはやはり托鉢するときは黙って回るという
そういう意味じゃないんで
ムニっていうのは まあ一応禅院というね
聖者っていう  じゃあパーリ語でサマナとかアジャリアって使ってる
一応この場合はこの悟った人を一応意味していますよ
悟った人はもう完全に供養に値するんですよ
完璧に だからムニといえば悟った人っていう意味になる
お釈迦様の使う単語で
わかりました ありがとうございます
あと えーと クチャが先に手を挙げます
この人間界に生まれてきたら
罪を犯さずに生きていることは
犯さずに生きられることはないということだったと思うんですが
で まあとにかく生まれてきてしまったので
最上の選択をする 罪をなるべくしないで徳を積むというか
あの とにかく罪を犯さないような生き方をしたいと思った時に
出家という選択があるって思うんですけれども
その選択はじゃあこの世の中で最上のものなんですか
まああのね そこはそうじゃないよ
それは社会的に考えてるんですよ
私はどう生きていればいいかって
そこで問題は解決しません
で 答えは万人に共通していないと仏教的な答えじゃないんですよ
例えば出家すればいいやと思ったら
みんな出家しちゃう それで社会は崩れちゃうでしょうに
いや でも私もあのみんなこの前ミャンマーに旅した時に
なんでみんな出家しないのかなって
出家した方が楽だし いいこといっぱいあるし
皆さんみんなから尊敬されてるし
いろんな人に会って なんで男の人なんですけど
ほとんど なんであなた出家しないの？出家しないの？って思ったら
やっぱり自分は俗世間でやりたいことがあるとか
結婚したいだとか 遊びたいだとかっていうことがあるから
みんながそれがいい道だと思っても
やっぱり選ばない人はいるわけじゃないですか
そうではなくて そういう人々はこんな遊びで出家しない
誰も 尊敬されるんだからとかね
もってのほか そんなことはひっとっかけるも考えません
出家決める人は命かけるんですよ
だからもう半端な気持ち
まあ一時出家は誰でもやりますけど
半端な気持ちではやらないんです
そんな風に見えなくても
そんな風にそんな風に見えない人はたくさんいました
それは一時出家ですよ
いやいや そうではなくて
お布施も今日お話しされることは托鉢のことでたくさんお話していただいて
伝統的な托鉢を今はどうか分かりませんが
私が行った時にはもうあからさまにお金を要求されたりとか
お坊さんにね  それはありますよ
だから私は言ったでしょうに
今はもうみんな分かってない
道が道がずれてるんだと
だからそんなもんじゃないんだと
ブッダの出家の托鉢の世界は
だから今日私が言った説法は
もしかするとミャンマーの一人のお坊さんも知らないかも
だからそういうものがある
この世の中で最上の選択をしようと思って
自分の生き方の中でですね
出家というものがあるとするならば
それは最上ではないかなというふうに思うんですが
どうなんですか  だからそこはもう社会組織を見て出してる答えであって
仏教的な答えにはならないんです
仏教的な答えは心の問題ですと
だからどうしても生きていきたいというところは無明があって
だったら思い存分罪を犯せということになるんですよ
だから人は出家であろうか
在家であろうが なんで生きているうちに行かないのか
この欲はなんなのかと
心を清らかにするということに挑戦するんです
ただ ラーメン食べるか
うどん食べるか どうでもいいんです
そんなことは 生き方はね
心を清らかかないかということ
だから在家にも出家にも心を汚れないようにと生きていられる
例えば店をやっている
店をやったとしても いつでも穏やかな気持ちで
どうせ家族にご飯食べさせなくちゃいけないんだから迷惑だとか
そういう軽い気持ちでね
あの連中も学校に行くんだから
おもちゃも買ってあげなきゃいけないんだから
商売するぞとかね ということで
一応その義務を果たすと
でお客さんにもすごいサービスをしてあげて
もう穏やかな気持ち 欲はない
でもただもう生きるためにそのシステムを動かしているだけで
そういう生き方あるんですよ
だからその 例えばブッダの教えを知っている人は店やっていると
その人 この店をとことん繁栄してやるぞとかね
もっともっと売り上げをね
とことん上げてやるぞという気持ちはないんです
これが危ない そんなことになっちゃうと
欲が出しちゃうと罪を犯すんだと
欲を出すんじゃなくて
私はこのシステムの中でどんなシステムを選んで家族を養って自分も楽にいられるのかっていうところだけで考えて
要は心清らかにすることやと
だから暇があったらもう瞑想して
それなりになんとか仏教を勉強するなり
それもやったりして このそういう生き方をするんですね
だからメインテーマは心を清らかにするっていうことにする
出家するか在家でいるかということじゃメインテーマじゃなくて
これはラーメン食べるかうどん食べるかっていうふうな話で
それだったら万人にできるはずなんです
出家こそ唯一な抜け道やと思っちゃうと
万人にできないんですよ
だからお釈迦様は出家こと最上たる道であると一言も仰ったとこはないんです
で 説法を聞い 聞いた人々は勝手にそれなら私は出家するぞという思うだけで
そうですからいいよと言うんです
お釈迦様  それなら出家しますと言って出家するのはいいんですか？ それは個人の好みで
個人の好みで  するんであって
個人は自分で責任持たなくちゃいけない
なぜか出家世界は結構厳しいんです
例えば自由自在といって逆になるんです
もう自我はひとかけらももう通じません
出家した時点でもう自我捨てなくちゃいけない
自我あるにも関わらず
自我捨てて生き方っていうのはすごい苦しいんですよ
サイケデは色々立場があったり色々あったりしたんですけど
もうゴミ扱いされて だから自分でちゃんと責任取って私がやりますと自分が約束しないと出家できません
強引にできません だからあの出家のみ唯一な道と思っちゃうとダメですよ
出家しなくても人間であるならば
悟りの道はもうオープンなんですよ
そのシェルターに入りたいなと思って入っちゃダメなんですか？シェルターに入っちゃダメなんですか？サンガというシェルターに入りたいと思って入るのはさ
それはもう全然  シェルターに入るのは一部の人間だけだからね
だからシェルターに入ってもまだ違いますからね
サイケデで良かったと思う時もありますよ
微妙なことでも入ったらそれで罪で扱いますからね
サイケデは罪でも何でもないことを出家したら罪になるんですよ
ものすごい厳しいんですよ
それに耐えられるかないかとかね
大変です だから あんまり仏教を知っている人々は出家したがらないんですよ
俺は遊びたいよとかね
その罪を犯したい気持ちじゃないんです
すごく素直で色々やりたいの
結婚もしたいし お姉ちゃんと遊びたいとかね
サイケデ別にそれは罪にならないんだけど
出家は一人で女性と 3つの言葉以上しゃべっちゃうと
これは戒律違反になってますよ
女性と喋りたければ ものすごい頭のいい物事わかる男性誰かがいなきゃダメなんです
自分の妹が来たと思ってください
私の妹がいるんだからね
いい加減でわがままでも平気でいろいろまあ家族でいろんなたくさん来るんだから問題ないんだけど
妹が一人で来ちゃうと
もう何のことない もうどこにいるの？っていう感じで
もうもう私の部屋に入ったりする
妹だから何と言えんでしょ
ギャーギャーギャーギャーと
あれやこれやとかね それでもやっぱり出家としてはまずいんですよ
だからまあもうお釈迦様時代あったんですよ
もう出家してて これって何やともう大変やと
私も帰りますよと帰った人いますよ
もう耐えられなくなっちゃって
これってシェルターって意味ではないんです
一応言えば戦場に入るような感じなんですよ
だから国民はみんな兵隊にならなくちゃっていうことはないでしょうしね
できる人だけになればいいし
だらしない連中が兵隊になっちゃうとね
かえって危ないでしょ
だからそういうふうなことではなくて
ブッダのこと答えっていうのは
病気に薬を治療するような感じなんですよ
だから病気があって それに適応する薬があるならば
それは万人に効くはずなんです
本当の薬であるならばね
そういうことで この輪廻がもう完全にとんでもない
もうもうカカコリで良くないもの
危ないやばいものであるというならば
なんでやばいものかというと
心の汚れなんですよ それが落とせと
例えば 100万の束を持っているんだからといって
えらい欲張りやってことはないんですよ
ただの物質やと これでいろいろ物々交換できるね
そんなのはね ただ口あるだけのってそういう気持ちでいる人もいるし
何でこれ隠してこなくちゃ
もうこれはみんなバレたらあかんぞと思う人もいるし
夫婦でも仲良くしていたのに
もう一人目ちょっと楽もないかところで奥さんにというのは
そこはすごい執着欲でしょ
だから生き方で計算するんじゃなくて
心で見るんですよ 問題は
だから挑戦はいかに清らかに心でいられるのか
いかに無執着でいられるのかっていう挑戦なんです
そうなると どんな一人でも挑戦できる
だから仏教とは国の総理大臣になってはいけないという話じゃないんです
総理大臣になれと あんたに資格があればね
それぐらいもできればね
でも俺が総理大臣だぞとか
それだったら地獄行きやと
執着だけするなよと 奴隷みたいに国民のために働けと
それが総理大臣の仕事です
そうすると あんたは立派なことをする
それでもって徳を積めますよと
支配者になったらもう地獄行き
仏教で王様はもう奴隷ですよ
結局は国民の奴隷みたいな感じになれと
奴隷って言葉を使わないんですけど
仏教はそういう制度さえも嫌だから父親と自分の子供だと
国民を粗末にするなと
子供はどうせ嫌なわがまま言うでしょうに
そんな環境を作れと それだったら王政でもすごい立派でしょうにね
国民があんたね 王様これは何やもうもうこれこれしなさいとかね
ガチャガチャガチャガチャ言うような感じになると
王様はいはいはい わかりますよと
黙っていなさいよ もうこれ 2年かかりますよとかね
やってあげますからとかね
そういう感じだったらすっごい立派でしょ
でもまあ 俗世間の政治システムというのは罪ばっかりなんですけどね
だから仏教の世界ではもうもう政治やってる政治やりなさい
医者になったから医者になれと
もうみんな欲張ったけど
どうやらやってくださいと
それは問題ないんです
しかし 武器作らないと麻薬売買を戦争のためにやめなさいと
動物売買もやめなさいと
それは 5つだけ商売を禁止しているんですよ
それ以外は 悟れないぞとは言ってない
悟れないというのは 母殺したら父殺しちゃうと
サンガをもう分裂させちゃうと
もうあんたはもうアウトです
それから出家しているあのサンガを起こしたりしちゃうとね
悟れないと それも今世ダンマ
永久的に悟れないわけじゃないんです
エネルギー論だから その積みのエネルギーがなくなると
もうまた復活はできる
そういうことだから すごくオープンですよ
だから皆様はこの伝統的なこの文化
ミャンマーとかね そちらで仏教もありながら文化もありますし
そのまま輸入はできないんですよ
皆様は別な人間だから
日本人だから 日本文化だから
この普遍的な真理のみを取った方がいいんです
時空関係超えているインファメスな真理があるんです
それだけ取っちゃえばいい
例えば心清らかにせなさいっていうのは
これは日本人であろうとアメリカ人であろうが関係ない話でしょう
ミャンマー人も同じことでしょう
アメリカ人の家でスイミングプールに付いてテニスコートもあるんだからといって
別にどうったことないです
そんなことで 欲張ってるとダメであって
無小弱でも一応付いているものは付いているんだからっていうだったら別にそれは問題はありません
よろしいですか すいませんが
最後にお一人にしていただいて
どうぞ  確かに長老のおっしゃるように
我々は今を過ごすために生活を営ないといけない
そのために我々も野菜を植えて
それを取って食べたり
あるいはいいものを食べたり
力を入れて成長を見て喜ぶ
我々のこの外側の世界
三次元の世界自体もそうですけどね
我々の内側の世界はそのまままた同じように我々の内側が良くなるというか
自然発生的に良くなることはなくて
我々はその内側のジャングルを切り開いてですね
畑を耕して野菜を植えて栽培しないと
我々の内側のいいものも育たないというか
するんですね 先ほどの外側の世界から我々は生命体を害さないと生きられないんだという内側の世界では
またこれとは別の論理が働いて
もっと独自のそのサーダと言いますか
霊的修行 精神的霊的な存在である我々が目指すところのその欲求の修業が長い長い通して一つになるんです
花が開く 野菜が実るようになるような開花ですか
いう御礼に至り得るというふうな希望と言いますか
光ともしれません そういうものを期待したいんですけど
それでよろしいのでしょうか
うーん 聞き取れなかったな
ちょっとどなたかこの話をよく聞こえたらちょっと省略して言ってくれますか
ちょっとね 声が低くてね
ここまで届かないんですよ
最初の方はちょっとわかんない
それから内側の世界っていうのは何のことかちょっとわかんないですね
じゃあもうちょっとかいつまんで
外側の世界では我々が食うために
例えば野菜を植え 栽培して
栄養って取って食べるわけです
同じように外側の世界じゃなくて内側の世界では
内側の世界で実りを取るためには
やはり畑を耕して野菜を植えて
収穫を得て それを取るという作業がもっと微妙な形で
外側で我々が百姓をやって取る形ではなくて
もっと微妙な形でそれを収穫する必要があると思うと
つまり長老がおっしゃるように
それがいわゆる仏道の修行であり
ヴィパッサナーであり
なるほど  つまりその  ずっとこの方に行ったのは同じこと
言うなら心育てるっていうね
畑だけじゃなくて心も育ててほしい
そうすると理解しやすいと思いますよ
我々はもうちゃんと田んぼは作る
それは仕事であって 肉体
外側の世界のことであって
それだけではもう全く足らない
食い物だけだ だから心の畑もちゃんと耕してほしいんですね
むしろそちらの方が我々の生きる上で
それが唯一 これが本職なんですよ
そうすると輪廻から脱出できるんです
キリストは人はパンのみで生きるにあたって
身ようなところと体で生きるというのもありますけども
そこの心がないと我々が本当のところ希望というんですか
光 それをなしに動物的に生きるということで
ある意味本当に生きていないという気がするんです
キリスト教の次元レベルではちょっと仏教と比較できませんだけどね
まあこちらはかなり違いますからね
キリストが言ってるのはね
もう魂もありますよという話ですけどね
パンのみで生きていられませんというのは
もう懺悔して神様の恵みが必要だよというね
単純な話ですけど でも生きるために説法しちゃうと
それ説法じゃないんです
例えば心の畑も耕して完全に生きているぞと言ったっても何の意味もないんです
それも輪廻ですからね
だからそこら辺はちょっと今理解できなくてもいいんですけど
じゃあ今はここまで理解してください
心にある殺生 怒り 憎しみ
欲 この殺生を全部取り除いて
智慧と慈しみという立派なものを育てた方がいいんです
そうすると確実に幸福
罪のない人生になります
で 例えば私が百万円持ったんだからといって罪を犯しているわけじゃないんですよ
俺が百万円持ってるぞというところが罪なんです
心汚れているんだから
心汚れてないんだったら罪でも何でもないんです
ただの紙の何枚か 百枚ですよ
だから自分の内から出てくるアプローチに対して気をつけてください
そこに来るまでに時間もかかりますね
いえいえ そんな簡単ですよ
時間かかっちゃうと先に死んじゃいますよ
そう思わない方がいいんですよ
すぐ即座にできるんだと
心 怒り 憎しみなんかはね
もうこんなもうこれは危ないやと
これはもう爆弾やと思って慈しみを実践する
慈悲の瞑想はぐちゃぐちゃやる
簡単に心変わりますよ
それからもう論理的にいつでも物事を見ようとする
その２つ で 日本ではあまり理屈っぽいのは好まれませんだけど
理屈っていう意味ではなくて
淡々と ちょっと論理的に理性に物事を見る
その２つを試せば もうそんなに時間かからないと思います
決してすごい難しいと思わない方がいいんですよ
そんなすごい難しいことだったら
お釈迦様の教えもどうったことはないんですよ
お釈迦様方は真理は膨大でものすごい広大無辺かもしれませんだけど
実践は万人にできるように語られていますよ
それがまたお釈迦様のすごいところなんですよ
だからすごいお釈迦様っていうのは大
偉大なる父なんですよ
私たちにいろいろ迷惑をかけるようにできそうもないものを頼んでいるわけじゃないんですよ
父親っていうのは 子供にいろんなことをやらせますけど
できそうもないことをやらせませんよ
いつでも子供の能力を向上することを見ながら
例えば子供は将棋やりたいと言ったら
父親が相手になりますよ
父親がプロだったらとことんプロで攻撃はしませんよ
でも 自分よりも才能がうまくいくようにと
父親が子供には一生懸命やってあげる
父親が苦労してプロになったかもしれませんだけど
子供は楽々にプロになっちゃうんです
父親のおかげで そういうことだから
お釈迦様っていうのは父なんですよ
我々の だから無理を一つも言ってない
すごくうまくできるようにと教えていますから
もうそれほど難しくないと思った方がいいんです
まあ実際に難しくないんです
実際に よろしいですか
じゃあちょっと時間がちょっと過ぎましたので
このダンマパダの部はここで終了させていただきます
この後はあの ちょっと時間過ぎてますが
普通五時半なんですけど
五時四十五分まで休憩取りまして
そこから主旨者の瞑想会をやりたいと思います
主旨者の方は座布団だけ持ちになって三階の方へお上がりください
あと一回こちらで集めてください
じゃあこちらの方に一回五時四十五分に集まってください
その時またもう一回失礼いたします
じゃあこれで終わります
では どうもありがとうございます